time for the awards coming out of week
eight michael david smith joins us let's
get right to it mds offensive player of
the week who you got
travis fulgam the eagles offense did not
look good
against a bad cowboys defense
except when they were throwing the ball
to travis fulgan and he's been amazing
he was cut by three different teams in
the month before the start of the
regular season
didn't even get on the active roster
until week four
since week four he's the nfl leader in
receiving yards he has been a remarkable
story
and i was extremely impressed with how
he played in the context of how badly
the rest of that offense was playing on
sunday night
mds my pick did not come out of nowhere
his name is patrick mahomes and i know
it was just against the jets but still
it was 419 yards 416 yards five
touchdowns by the end of the game he's
standing over on the sideline and in
case anyone had forgotten about patrick
mahomes in the mvp conversation he put
his name right back in that conversation
he's second to russell wilson in
touchdowns and passer rating and you
know what he's only thrown one
interception this year put his name in
mvp conversation
he's got 21-1 in seven games eight games
excuse me russell wilson has
26 and six in seven games he's on pace
for more touchdowns he means more to his
team i think than patrick mahomes
because wilson doesn't have the
supporting cast i think it may come down
to those two and one of the big factors
may be which team gets the number one
seed if one of the two ultimately does
for me it's dalvin cook for all reasons
that i just expressed in the last
segment of the program four touchdowns
first time a vikings player has done it
in 41 years cook one of the best running
backs in the nfl needs to stay healthy
he could actually pull the vikings back
into the race for the seventh seed or
the eighth seed if there is one if he
can stay healthy for the balance of the
season mds defensive player of the week
time who you got
i got darius leonard who returned to the
colts lineup and made a big difference
when he is in there the colts defense is
as good as any defense in the league
the lions they they just could not run
the ball with darius leonard in the game
i think adrian peterson and john swift
combined average like one yard for kerry
in the game uh darius leonard is a
really special player i think he's as
good an inside linebacker as there is in
the nfl right now
mds i picked the miami defense and i
think you could have picked any of those
11 players but i'm going with eric rowe
i just thought he had an outstanding a
game for the dolphins you know that
defense forced four turnovers they
scored on one uh they set up td drives
of 33-1 yards i mean they were just the
difference in that game with the way tua
was playing he had seven tackles and
interception and five pass breakups eric
rowe and that entire dolphins defense
was just outstanding on sunday
i noticed before the steelers ravens
game on sunday mark caboli of the
athletic previously the pittsburgh
tribune review tweeted that he thinks
stefan tua is going to have a big game
for the steelers and he did
nine tackles two sacks three tackles for
lost three quarterback hits he was all
over lamar jackson there was one play
where he just got a push up the middle
it's almost like there was no one
blocking him he got into the backfield
so quickly it was aaron donald type
stuff and uh it was an amazing
performance part of an amazing defense
that i think is going to have a
defensive player of the week each and
every week as we proceed through the
season all right rookie of the week time
mds
i went with jk dobbins even though he
did it in a losing effort for the ravens
because he had such an outstanding aim
particularly when you look at what that
steelers defense had been doing to
running backs all season they had
stopped all running backs on about 25
of all carries they faced this season
they had stopped about 25 of the time
the running back for no gain jk dobbins
was never held to less than two yards on
any carry averaged 7.5 yards a carry
just had a terrific game even in a
losing effort against the steelers
mds i am going with zach moss the bill's
running back got to throw some love to
the bills for their victory over the
patriots they had 119 rushing yards and
he was a big part of that he had 14
carries 81 yards and two touchdowns in
the victory over the patriots just a
great job with devin singletary running
the ball and josh allen had some big
runs too but those guys just made made
it so easy on josh allen in the passing
game because of the way they ran the
football
yeah that was one of the struggles of
the bills and back to dobbins mark
ingram had to look at that performance
on sunday by the ravens and realize he's
not gonna be on that team next year he's
got a 5 million salary unless he takes a
huge pay cut and maybe they'll offer him
one
they're just at the point where it's
time to cycle through to the younger
guys because the younger guys get it
done and jk dobbins clearly got it done
for me look i think i need to name the
rookie of the week the joe burrow
memorial rookie of the week award even
though he's obviously alive but uh
because i would pick him every week and
i'm going to try to consciously not pick
him i want to spread it around a little
bit i'm going to go with trayvon diggs
the cowboys rookie defensive back he had
a rough start to the season a rough
start to the game against the eagles but
he finished with two interceptions and
yes they lost but it's
to the extent that there are very very
few bright spots on that cowboys roster
shireen as you well know trayvon diggs
was one of them on sunday night so
so he has that going for him i'm sure
like they'd rather win the game but at
least they got something
out of week eight all right coach of the
week mds who you got
well i got rahim morris and it comes
down to for me what bill parcell said
you are what your record says you are
the falcons were oh and five with dan
quinn and now they're two in one with
raheem morris including thursday's win
over the panthers i think morris is
making a strong case that he deserves to
be the falcons head coach on a permanent
basis that decision won't be made
anytime soon but they gave him a long
portion of the season the last 11 games
to prove himself i i think the falcons
dug too big a hole for themselves to
realistically get into playoff
convention but i think if morris can get
them close to 500 i think they ought to
give him the job on a full-time basis
mds i'm going with another chief and yes
i know they just played the jets i
understand the jets may not even qualify
as a nfl team much less a good nfl team
but andy reid
joined curly lambeau in all time fifth
place tied for fifth place all-time wins
including the postseason uh and which
has just been outstanding as a head
coach 229 wins all time now including
the postseason uh and and it's just been
great
at everything sometimes we take we take
him for granted for how good he's been
as a head coach
for me it's uh and i'm gonna stick with
the the vikings game it's it's got to be
mike zimmer um dalvin cook told me after
the game zimmer's been very very hard on
them lately for blowing leads cook said
he responds
to that well obviously he did
zimmer was flexible on defense used a
lot of cover too as we mentioned earlier
to try to confuse the green bay packers
and also something cook told me you know
and and this is more zimmer's staff but
zimmer's in charge of the staff he
empowers the guys to do this cook comes
to the sideline and he tells kennedy
polamalu his position coach he tells
rick dennison the offensive line coach
what's working and they adjust the game
plan to fit what cook sees and obviously
it worked on sunday against the packers
so kudos to mike zimmer that was a game
the vikings desperately needed in a very
very bad season
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports